le câble sous marin kanawa relie la
guyane et la martinique
donc c'est une décision qui a été prise
il ya deux ans par le pdg d'orange
stéphane richard et deux ans plus tard
on assiste à la fin des travaux
ce câble va permettre d'une part de
sécuriser le trafic internet entre les
antilles et la guyane martinique
guadeloupe guyane et les états unis et
la métropole puisque c'est une troisième
route qui va permettre d'acheminer les
données on a déjà le câble america's 2
et le câble ses fesses et le câble
kanawa est une troisième route qui va
permettre de sécuriser à leur foi pour
la guyane mais aussi pour la martinique
et la guadeloupe
ce cas
les usages augmente il ya de plus en
plus de trafic de données on a plus 50 %
chaque année
l'augmentation du trafic de données et
donc ça va permettre dans les 25 à 30
années à venir de vendre encore plus de
capacité